after overwhelming bipartisan support in
Congress yesterday president Trump
signed into law the largest economic aid
package in history aimed at easing the
burden on workers and businesses
suffering from the pandemic Nikole
Killion is at the White House with more
Nicole Jeff in just a few hours
President Trump will head to Norfolk
Virginia to see off the USNS comfort an
able hospital ship that will be bound
for the epicenter of the outbreak in New
York doesn't mean that I'm gonna be
shaking people's hands but I think it
sends a signal when President Trump says
he wants to show his support for the
USNS comfort which expedited repairs and
stopped up medical supplies this week
even if it goes against his
administration's own guidelines
discouraging travel for some Americans
the Virginia visit comes a day after the
president signed the cares Act a
sweeping two point two trillion dollar
package to provide financial assistance
to cope with the impact of the corona
virus epidemic the centerpiece of the
new law includes direct payments to most
Americans checks will be sent to
individuals of up to $1,200 twice that
for couples and an additional $500 for
each child it also boost unemployment
benefits and provides hundreds of
billions of dollars for small and large
businesses today is a very big but we
have much more to do Friday the
president also used the defense
production act to order General Motors
to make ventilators after negotiations
didn't get there we have to get these
people on board we're not looking to get
into a big deal on price we're not
looking to be ripped off on price the
president said over 100,000 ventilators
will be produced in the next 100 days he
dismissed complaints from some
governor's about the federal response
and suggested the vice president should
not call those who aren't appreciative
if they don't treat you right I don't
call he's a different type of person
he'll call quietly anyway okay but he's
done a great job he should be
appreciated for the job he's done one
governor the president has been singling
out is Michigan's Gretchen Whitmer he
tweeted last night she doesn't have a
clue Widmer has been sounding the alarm
saying her state doesn't have enough
personal protective equipment she
tweeted we should be focused on fighting
the virus not each other
Dana Nicole some wise words there thank
you